our kelly has been in jail since 2019
and now he'll add 30 years to his time
behind bars welcome to entertainment
tonight with some of his victims in
court today the disgraced r b star's
fate was sealed in this high-profile sex
trafficking trial
this is effectively a life sentence
this man is a prolific serial predator
who utilized his status as a grammy
award-winning household name to inflict
pain and anguish on so many victims
when you get convicted of sex
trafficking and racketeering you expect
a large prison sentence before
sentencing the court heard impact
statements from seven of kelly's victims
including lizette martinez i actually
blamed myself for so long for the abuse
legal expert jessie weber says the
victims didn't hold back during
testimony of one of these survivors
speaking to his attorney and she stopped
and said i don't want to interrupt his
conversation clearly nothing can get in
the way
e.t was there for the major turning
points in the case first the gail king
factor the cbs morning's co-host spent
80 minutes interviewing r kelly and
earned praise for keeping her cool
i thought a couple of times that maybe
we're witnessing a breakdown as it's
happening this is not me i'm fighting
for my life
y'all killing me
he was very much aware of what he was
doing but i also thought that on some
level we were watching someone who was
really needed help and needed help right
away this ain't not about music i'm
trying to have a relationship with my
kids and i can't do it
y'all just don't want to believe the
truth
you don't want to believe it i think the
gayle king interview didn't play a
factor into whether or not archon was
gonna be convicted of these crimes this
kind of gave you a glimpse into what was
going on in his mind how panicked he was
for the first time in his life he had to
really consider that he was going to be
facing criminal charges
our kelly has brought so much pain to so
many people john legend denounced r
kelly and lady gaga apologized for
working with him in 2013.
calling the collaboration poor judgment
when i was young also fueling outrage
the docuseries surviving kelly was
pivotal in the prosecution of this case
over 50 people including our kelly's ex
and several victims of sexual misconduct
made shocking allegations from there you
saw the charges in chicago you saw the
charges in new york
charges in minnesota i'm not sure
without that documentary we would even
be where we are today
[Music]